[Musique]
on retrouve Véronique Michel seoget
Jonathan Trudeau bonsoir bonsoir
je le disais sa barbe un peu dans les
relations fédérales provinciales mais
commençons quand même par le plat de
résistance on est en vie encore la
répercussions de cette démission de
sophie Brochu hier je vous fais écouter
ceux qui étaient pas peut-être en ville
hier un petit bout de l'entrevue ou à
nous disait ça n'a rien à voir avec des
chicanes ou des différences de vue tout
va bien on écoute on revient
c'est pas que monsieur fait djiban et
moi ont pu savoir des divergences sur
une
des choses peuvent exister mais c'est
pour ça qui fait que je quitte en fait
je vous dirais même si c'était ça je
resterai si c'était juste ça puis que je
pensais qu'avec quelque chose qui
marchait pas je me battrai à mort
je veux entendre je donne la parole
ensuite monsieur Lego ce matin qui est
allé dans le même sens venant c'est des
textes prévus on écoute
sa fille avait pas de contrairement à ce
que certains ont dit de différence
d'orientation avec nous autres mais de
façon personnelle de choisir que pour
elle c'était le temps de passer à autre
chose je respecte ça
Jonathan je donne la parole en premier
donc ça c'est je le disais tout à
l'heure elle est partie avec élégance
dans le sens où elle a décidé de pas
casser de la vaisselle si tenté qu'elle
voulait casser de la vaisselle
il y a un élément qui qui me frappe
depuis 24 ans c'est que c'est un concert
déjà à l'endroit de sophie Brochu tout
le monde vente ses compétences vendre
ses qualités de communicatrice à quel
point elle était bonne et que c'est une
immense perte mais en même temps du même
souffle on dirait que tout le monde met
en doute sa parole lorsqu'elle dit
répète à nos âmes que il y avait pas de
de conflit marqué ou si on veut de
guerre larvée qui ont mené à son départ
même chose côté du Premier ministre moi
j'ai envie de dire que jusqu'à une
certaine mesure on doit les croire parce
que je pense qu'il y a probablement un
ensemble de facteurs qui ont mené madame
Rocher a quitté son emploi est-ce que le
fait qu'elle était pas à 100% aligné
avec le gouvernement avec les
orientations les velléités de du
ministre fait du Gabin peut-être que ça
jouait mais je pense que deux choses
aussi notamment le fait que lorsque
sophie Brochu a finalement accepté
l'offre la demande j'avais dit presque
la supplication de François Legault de
prendre la tête d'Hydro-Québec en pleine
pandémie elle avait déjà dit non par le
passé plusieurs reprises bon elle a
senti son sang du devoir mais c'était
pas dans le plan de carrière de sophie
Brochu c'était pas une idéale à
atteindre et le fait si on veut par je
le dis sans du devoir mais en même temps
il y a pas personne à qui j'ai parlé qui
passait madame Brochu passerait 5 10 15
ans à la taille des Québec donc oui
mais en même temps je le répète est-ce
que ça a pu jouer peut-être mais le
narratif à l'effet que vraiment il
claque la porte ou quoi que ce soit j'ai
un peu plus de difficultés
de ce comité qu'elle a réussi à mettre
sur pied cette demande en disant je ne
veux pas que le pouvoir soit uniquement
concentré dans les mains du super
ministre fait du début donc il y aura un
comité présidé par le premier qui a une
première rencontre le 19 décembre et
elle nous dit c'est après ça que j'ai
cheminé et puis le temps des faits donc
c'est comme si elle se disait peut-être
j'ai peut-être pas envie pendant les
deux trois prochaines années de négocier
avec un comité comme celui-là est-ce que
peut-être fait partie de la décision
c'est très possible que ça fait partie
de la décision une réunion comme ça une
semaine avant Noël
quand sa première réunion du comité
qu'on commence à se parler c'est pas ou
là où les choses se décident je pense
que ce qui était devenu évident pour
Madame bruschu c'est qu'elle n'était pas
sur la même longueur d'onde que le
gouvernement et Monsieur Lego quand il
fait le portrait robot de la personne
qui devrait remplacer madame Brochu il a
quasiment confirmé pour que ça soit
quelqu'un qui est en mode développement
faut qu'on augmente la capacité de
l'Hydro-Québec de 50% d'ici 2050 la
traduction de ça là c'est barrage
barrage c'est une façon de voir le
développement économique qui ressemble à
celui de de Robert bourasta Bida c'était
il y a 50 ans il n'était pas question
d'économie d'énergie là
il n'était pas question de la notion de
négawatts de d'économiser des watts que
c'est plus rentable que de que d'un
produire des nouveaux et on parle pas
d'éolien alors moi je possède madame
brochet était dans la vision du
gouvernement et un moment donné écouter
c'est la PDG dit au Québec une société
qui n'a qu'un seul actionnaire qui
s'appelle l'État du Québec puis l'État
du Québec
effectivement monsieur LEGO a donné ses
critères il faut que ce soit quelqu'un
en mode développement quelqu'un qui est
capable de travailler en équipe que déjà
géré une grande organisation ça c'est ce
que monsieur Legault a dit mais moi je
ne source ordonne qui m'a ajouté un
autre critère qui m'a dit quelqu'un qui
va être capable de faire plus plus vite
parce que c'est ça avec François Legault
et Pierre fitzgerbin ce sont des gens
qui veulent qu'on livre la marchandise
donc on comprend entre les lignes que
c'est ce que le prochain PDG devra faire
et Madame Brochu ben c'est peut-être pas
nécessairement qu'elle ne correspondait
pas à ces critères là mais visiblement
il y a des choses qui se sont passées
cet automne qui faisait en sorte que
peut-être qu'il y a une certaine brisure
aussi dans la relation lorsqu'elle a
expliqué qu'elle voulait pas que le
Québec devienne le dolorama
hydroélectricité c'est clair qui ont pas
aimé cette déclaration là de la part
d'une PDG de la plus grande société
d'État il trouve qu'elle aurait dû
garder une certaine réserve alors il y a
peut-être une accumulation de plein de
choses et pour le moment effectivement
on ne connaîtra pas totalement la raison
parce que Madame Brochu est pas la fin
de sa carrière quand même est encore là
je commence avril puis après il va
vouloir se trouver un autre emploi mais
Jonathan il y a quand même le faité
qu'effectivement dans toutes ces
déclarations dans toutes ces entrevues
dans son plan elle mettait en premier
lieu l'économie d'énergie puis après
bien sûr d'accroître la capacité de
production du Québec mais c'est comme si
le gouvernement
cet élément-là arrive plus vite que dans
la tête de Madame Brochu
mais en même temps moi je veux souligner
que
à mon sens là on fait de l'analyse les
visions de Madame Brochu et de Pierre
fils Gabin ne sont pas dit à métralement
opposé on n'est pas dans une espèce de
vision manichéenne ou tout ce que Sophie
voulait faire c'était de l'efficacité
énergétique et que tout ce que monsieur
fait du Gabin veut faire c'est de
développer développer développer dans le
plan stratégique de sophie Brochu il y
avait aussi la notion d'augmenter la
capacité il y avait la notion d'évaluer
le potentiel à développer davantage de
projet hydroélectriques donc est-ce
qu'elle allait au même rythme
canderonique par exemple dit aller plus
vite peut-être que il n'était pas
exactement sur la même longueur d'onde
mais madame Brochu elle-même le disait
que c'était être sain ou si un moment
donné d'avoir certains points
une opportunité d'avoir quelqu'un 100%
aligné ce serait difficile de lui
reprocher de vouloir ça
oui oui mais c'est pas c'est ça mais
sans reprocher il y avait que vous avez
raison de le dire c'est pas blanc ou
noir parce que les deux il y avait le
cercle commun entre les deux positions
est très très grand mais peut-être qu'il
y avait des accents un peu plus pressés
d'un côté un peu moins précis de l'autre
mais bon bref elle décide de partir deux
ans avant son mandat toujours est-il et
là Monsieur le go on va l'écouter Jean
de vous entendre il dit mais
d'affaires collective sur l'énergie la
grande transition énergétique au Québec
je vais parler à tous les chefs de
parties de ça puis on écoute ça pour
rien
dès la semaine prochaine les dates
commencent à être fixées je vais
rencontrer les quatre chefs d'opposition
incluant le Parti conservateur du Québec
pour écouter leur suggestion d'abord sur
ce dossier là comment on réussit
l'électrification du Québec mais aussi
sur les autres priorités
bon alors comment vous comprenez ça
Véronique
c'était une promesse postélectorale
l'avait dit au lendemain de sa victoire
qui voulait rencontrer tous les chefs et
c'est sûr qu'il y a une question d'image
aussi là-dedans je ne veux pas douter de
la bonne foi dans une démocratie quand
il y a 90 députés monsieur Legault en
quelque part je pense qu'il veut
réellement entendre ce que les autres
chefs ont à dire parce que toujours même
des gens qui les ont élus mais c'est sûr
que il y a eu premièrement
labandon de la réforme du mode de
scrutin ensuite de ça le l'élection a
montré les limites de notre système
électoral il y a des gens qui ont été
déçus de voir que le parti de
conservateur n'était pas représenté ou
que par exemple le Parti québécois
devait se battre pour avoir du
financement Québec solidaire devait se
battre pour obtenir une reconnaissance
officielle donc tout ça fait en sorte
qu'il a entendu la frustration et qu'il
a pas vraiment le choix de tenir cette
promesse là finalement des rencontrer
est-ce que Michel sait il va
est-ce qu'il y aura des propositions
l'opposition qui peuvent cheminer
pourquoi pas et aboutir en quelque part
il pourrait y en avoir 6 sa rencontre
les objectifs de Monsieur Legros
évidemment ça sera jamais de mauvaise
chose que le premier ministre rencontre
les chefs des parties d'opposition
évidemment mais en même temps il faut
pas s'attendre non plus à ce que les
chefs d'opposition sortent de là en
disant moi j'ai une entente parfaite
avec tout va bien c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe
noir se parler ils vont pouvoir se
surpris ils vont pouvoir se parler ils
vont pouvoir aussi travailler parce que
ça c'est important sur le calendrier
parlementaire on dit souvent le
gouvernement propose le positionne quand
les projets doigts sont adaptés ces
choses-là doivent être discutées en
quatre yeux le Premier ministre des
chefs d'opposition ça c'est une bonne
affaire maintenant ça permet aussi de
l'autre savoir où sont les dangers pour
lui ou quelle est la ligne rouge de
chacun des parties qui dit ça si vous
essayez de faire ça d'une autre on sera
jamais avec vous pour voir on va vous
combattre alors il y a comme un échange
de renseignements là-dedans qui est bon
pour tout le monde Jonathan
doublement un bon coup de François
Legault cette sortie là parce que bon la
fameuse main tendue qu'il avait promise
lors quoi du discours inaugural ou la
fermentation du Conseil des ministres
bien il vient son vœu la matérialiser
puis quand je doublement il y a l'aspect
aussi je note l'aspect qui l'inclut Éric
dumm donc les gens qui disent que le le
le la volonté démocratique ne s'exprime
pas l'Assemblée nationale avec l'absence
de M ben là on va l'inclure dans ces
discussions là ceci étant dit ce qui
parfois peut apparaître comme peut être
une bonne idée au départ peut s'avérer
être un piège à moyen terme au long
terme pourquoi ben parce qu'on va
vouloir voir justement des résultats si
on a l'impression que Monsieur Lego
rencontre les chefs d'opposition
uniquement pour les kodaks pour la
galerie et pour le bien pareil mais
qu'il fait fit de toutes les
recommandations qu'il ne démontrent
aucune ouverture mais ça pourrait se
revirer contre lui donc évidemment on
sera on sera l'affût on sera attentif
bon Toronto Star oui là
qui selon les sources de rontostat
qui a dit que l'Ontario était prêt à
accepter les conditions de Monsieur
Trudeau pour avoir de nouveaux fonds en
santé premier tour de table ce serait la
fin du fameux front commun que les gens
disent ça tient jamais Michel si vous en
avez vu d'autres
ça serait donc la preuve que c'est il
n'est pas il n'a pas tenu
oui mais je pense que c'est la première
fois que je vois le front comme un
tromper avant qu'il soit formellement
annoncé on était on était en train de de
se dire à la dernière conférence des
ministres que oui il faut qu'on se parle
entre les provinces faut qu'on a un fond
commun mais il n'était pas formé là
encore et Monsieur monsieur Ford qui
a une nouvelle amie à Monsieur Trudeau
disons là depuis ça depuis sa réélection
et beaucoup plus
facilement facile à convaincre de dire
écoutez la largeur vient toute la même
du même endroit et bien des
contribuables là chez moi les
juridictions puis on va faire quelque
chose il est beaucoup plus malléable à
ces arguments là que peuvent être par
exemple monsieur Lebeau ou d'autres
premiers ministres et donc ça fait que
il y a le repas de fonds communs de
toute façon ils ont tous
se sont tous effondrés ou à peu près et
la négociation se faisait de et puis
avec des résultats qu'on connaît avec
les promesses qui étaient toujours un
peu mécontente on a on a un extrait de
la réaction du bureau de monsieur
Legault Jonathan n'est pas très content
évidemment parce que c'est pas terminé
c'est loin de là cette négociation là
nous sommes prêts à continuer de
partager écrit le directeur des
communications l'ensemble de nos données
que nous collectons déjà pour offrir au
Québécois un système de santé efficace
et performant autrement dit plein ça
continue pour nous le partage de données
c'est une question de transparence ça
n'a pas besoin d'être une condition là
on joue sur les mots parce que docford
ce qu'il accepterait c'est effectivement
de partager des données qui a un centre
fédéral qui mesure les progrès à mesure
que l'argent arrive dans les provinces
ça peut ça que Trudeau d'ailleurs je
vous fais écouter ce que Monsieur
Trudeau nous disait moi je disais
pourquoi vous posez des conditions
c'est de la transparence on écoute
c'est de l'argent des contribuables et
si on va envoyer l'argent que les gens
payent au fédéral pour améliorer les
systèmes que les gens reçoivent c'est
normal qui est un certain niveau de
transparence
de la transparence
bon et c'est à ça que dogford aurait dit
oui Jonathan
ouais avant de faire l'autopsie du front
commun je dirais prudence prudence
prudence parce que j'ai parlé au cabinet
de François Legault on a vu la réaction
officielle je les ai senti très très
surpris je sais qu'ils sont en
communication avec le cabinet donc Ford
pour essayer de valider l'exactitude des
propos est-ce que Monsieur Ford ne
ferait pas partie du célèbre club
mais vous savez quoi Patrice le seul
autre endroit où j'ai senti plus de
prudence qu'à Québec c'est Ottawa
j'ai l'impression que même l'homme était
surpris de voir le degré du vertu de de
dogford donc moi on me dit on poursuit
les discussions mais ce que j'ai tenté
de voir si est-ce que une ouverture
parce que Québec on rappelle que
François Legault s'était dit plutôt
optimiste après sa dernière rencontre
avec Justin Trudeau donc là j'ai essayé
de voir est-ce que la fameuse rencontre
entre monsieur Trudeau et les premiers
ministres des provinces est-ce que c'est
davantage à l'agend seul l'était ma
compréhension c'est qu'on n'est pas là
du tout donc qu'est-ce qu'une avancée
avec l'ensemble des provinces est-ce que
l'Ontario s'apprête à faire cavalier
seul c'est pas confirmé
restons prudent comme vous dites parce
que et puis on joue sur les mots
Véronique là c'est Trudeau moi refusé de
parler du mot condition déjà c'est la
transparente ce qu'on veut c'est des
indicateurs communs pour les provinces
pour voir comment on avance si vous
appelez ça condition c'est très bien
mais c'est pas des cas alors ça va être
ça pendant quelques semaines mais pour
moi c'est pas clair puis avant d'aller
en onde j'en parlais avec le collègue
Sébastien Bovic on est allé réécouter
l'extrait de doc forme d'aller l'écouter
le l'extrait de la conférence de presse
la question du journaliste dit à ce que
vous êtes prêt à accepter des conditions
liées à la transparence des données donc
l'exemple sur lequel il insiste c'est
sûr la collecte de données donc est-ce
que docford à ce moment-là répondait
uniquement sur
conditions de la collecte de données ou
est-ce que il incluait les autres
conditions c'est pas clair en fait je
voudrais avoir un droit de relance
demain s'il y a effectivement un autre
point de presse de Monsieur Ford
est-ce que faudrait l'éclaircir parce
que quand il dit qu'il est prêt
l'accepter à ce qui est prêt à accepter
seulement la collecte de données ou les
autres conditions Michel
ce que le fédéral veut et d'ailleurs
s'amuser parce que l'ancien ministre des
Finances qui fait une promotion avec son
nouveau livre dans le Globe ce matin il
y avait l'extrait où il parle de ça Bill
morno qui dit si le fédéral donne plus
d'argent puis il faut que le fédéral
donne plus d'argent il faut que ça
vienne avec un système pour qu'on puisse
voir les progrès pour appeler ça des
conditions ou pas lui aussi va dans ce
sens là Michel
c'est quelque chose que ta voix demande
depuis des années Jean-Chrétien demander
ça on peut remonter très loin là-dedans
la réponse est elle est variable selon
les provinces c'était à peu près une
année avec des variations l'Ontario
toujours été plus proche du gouvernement
fédéral le Québec celui qui était le
plus loin au Québec a toujours dit
excusez-moi vous ne dirigez pas un seul
hôpital vous le gouvernement fédéral
vous avez pas nous dire comment diriger
nos hôpitaux sauf que ce que pas mal
toutes les provinces comprennent c'est
que la collecte de données et le premier
pas vers des normes fédérales quand
toutes les données tu les as pas corrigé
pour faire
un annuaire statistique à chaque année
là tu les connais je pour les utiliser
et c'est ça que les promesses craignent
il y a des différences entre les
systèmes de santé avec peignent un
médecin plus de soins d'une séance
que les provinces veulent garder moi je
fonctionne comme ça pourquoi vous me
diriez de changer alors que ça
fonctionne bien dans ma province
c'est ça mais Jonathan on sent qu'il y a
vraiment un bras de fer qui est loin
d'être terminé puisque le fédéral cette
fois-ci a pas l'air à vouloir lâcher le
morceau sur ce qui appelle la
transparence pour que il dise il faut
que les provinces puissent comparer leur
système pour qu'un émulation pour que si
ça marche ailleurs ça puisse marcher
mieux en fait au niveau du Québec
monsieur Lego disait un peu la même
chose pendant la pandémie en disant on
n'a pas d'indicateur c'est épouvantable
on est au Moyen-Âge
non et ce qui me fait signe c'est de
voir que quand monsieur Legault depuis
la rencontre au sommet de la
Francophonie du bon on s'entend sur sur
les données il s'empresse toujours de
dire on le fait déjà ce sont déjà sur
des des données qui sont publiques on
sait qu'au Québec s'il y a bien un
endroit où on a eu la difficulté c'est
au niveau de la connaissance de ce qui
se passait réellement dans dans le
réseau même chose et certaine c'est que
pour les gens que nous écoutent j'espère
que
ultimement le fédéral et le Québec et
les autres provinces vont finir par
s'entendre parce que au bout de tout ça
il y a un réseau il y a des patients qui
ont qui ont grandement besoin qu'on
puisse financer adéquatement notre
réseau il l'améliorer voilà les gens ont
hâte que les politiciens s'entendent
comme vous dites Véronique Michel C
Jonathan merci beaucoup bonne soirée au
bonne soirée bonne soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]